[Music]
hello and welcome to dear Hank and John
or as I prefer to think of it to you
John and Hank it's a podcast about
comedy and death where two brothers give
you dubious advice and answer your
questions and bring you all the week's
news from both Mars and AFC Wimbledon I
forgot to look at Mars news I just
realized now you usually ask me how I'm
doing how are you doing John I'm just
gonna keep giving you prompts the whole
time
I am well we are home from our tour it
was a whirlwind month together on the
bus it was magical it was long it was
wonderful I'm glad to be sleeping in the
same bed every night and back together
with my family so Hank you know what
I've been doing the last few days I've
been clearing honeysuckle from my
backyard
honeysuckle is an invasive bush and I
have been clearing it with an axe
and a machete and it feels great Hank
the good news is there is so much
honeysuckle in central Indiana I might
become the like Johnny Appleseed of
destroying honeysuckle like the reverse
Johnny honeysuckle Johnny honeysuckle
that's what they're gonna call me this
may be what I devote my life to because
I have found the last four or five days
to be so magnificently clarifying I have
no desire to do anything other than
clear honeysuckle from the world you may
be unsurprised to hear that I have been
in a lot of meetings over the last over
the last four days instead of doing what
you're doing talking to people about all
the things that I missed while I was out
of town and doing a bunch of scishow
videos and doing a Aeons shoot today and
deer hey John today I got the did our
foundation to decrease worldsuck Board
meeting this morning and talking about
the front end for awesome and how that's
gonna go talking about Peters amiss and
talk about dftba talk about VidCon
talking about pod con all the things I
feel like if I had a honeysuckle problem
in my yard it would be the worst
honeysuckle problem any yard has ever
had well good news Hank you have a bro
who is more than happy to fly to
Missoula and take care of that
honeysuckle I won't go to any of those
meetings that all sounds horrible I am
so glad when I hear you say that I'm
just so glad that you demoted me I'm so
glad to be reporting to you and no
longer to be co boss with you as my boss
by the way I need to ask for another
week off so I can clear some more
honeysuckle you know you take you take
all the time you need John that's what I
needed to hear and also what I required
to hear otherwise I would have quit Hank
let's answer some questions from our
listeners by the way I enjoyed doing
this on the phone with you it real life
is fun it's a little intense though
especially when there's 1200 people
watching I that it's not so much not
having you in the room it's not having
all of them Hank this first question
comes from Alice who writes dear John
and Hank my brother-in-law and I have
been puzzling over a question for a
while now and I would be very grateful
if you could give us an answer what is
the smallest part of the body you can be
a doctor in tempest e deck Sriram Alice
hmm
what's the largest part of the the body
you can be a doctor in let's start there
well it's fun the way the question was
phrased made me think about the movie
inner space where people like shrunk
down and being tiny people so they could
be a doctor inside of someone's body
mm-hmm um what's the smallest doctor you
can be in a body part would be inner
space at the center question right the
answer to that is inner space I think
the biggest part of the body you can be
a doctor in has to be dermatology right
like isn't the skin the largest human
organ uh yeah
yeah well mmm I probably I don't know
there's also like bones there's a lot of
bones but I think cuz cuz like bones
don't really count as an organ but you
can be like a bone doctor you can also
just be a doctor of like everything like
it just a general practitioner is just a
doctor of the whole body theoretically
and then when you have like a more
specific problem they're like oh go see
my friend Jeremiah he just looks at toes
right and more I would also argue that
perhaps the largest part of the body you
can be a doctor in
is psychiatry because of course like you
know the mind contains infinite vastness
--is huh right I'm like you like that
that might have been too much no that's
very good that's good
no I'm there with you John okay the
smallest part of a body you can be a
doctor in and bear in mind that Hank and
I are both MDS before all of this
YouTube stuff we pursued our medical
degrees would passed our boards and
everything and then we just gave it all
up to read teleprompters the smallest
part of the body you can be a doctor and
I believe has to be a gland right like
maybe the pituitary gland yeah how big
is the pituitary mmm I believe it is the
size of a walnut pituitary gland size of
space fish is the first autocomplete
well that is incorrect it is an intrical
and about the size of a pea that weighs
two point five grams in human that's
that's very small I bet you can be a
doctor of the pituitary gland do you
think it could be like a doctor of just
pores like I'm a doctor of pores pores
are very small well but you have to be a
doctor of one individual pore which
would be weird like I'm the doctor of
the pore right like the one that you
always get is it on right at the edge of
your nostril but on the doctor of that
pore please I need that doctor no he's
right unlike the crease in the crease
between my nose where my nose meets my
rest my face part which is weird Cano's
the party fish but you know what I mean
and it's like right in there and I don't
know why it's like extra irritating
there to have I know what you see there
mostly because I have noticed over the
years that you often get astonishingly
huge zits right there where you're
talking about thank you so much I'm glad
at least to know that you're looking at
my face a lot so that's nice you're
welcome
let's include that entire posnick it's
your turn a cue answer ask a question I
just let say I feel like there must be
something smaller that you could be a
doctor in no it's the pituitary gland
it's the size of a
P it's smaller than a total in any case
I'm frustrated that you got to the right
answer too fast introduces that means we
can answer more questions if you don't
ask one I will this next question
it comes from Jojo who asks dear Hank
and John why do we rub our eyes when we
are tired
wake me up before you jo-jo oh that's a
great name specific sign-off it's also a
question specific sign-off because they
need us to wake them up because they're
tired so I mean that month that might be
the greatest sign-off in the history of
dear Hank and John which is really
saying something
Hank why do we rub our eyes when we're
tired do you know no here's what I will
say that my view on this has changed
dramatically since having a child
because the for like one of the first
signals of like a state that my baby was
in like there was crying and I knew that
that was like the baby was in a in a bad
state and but one of the first ones that
wasn't crying was I rubbing and I was
like oh you're tired you're rubbing your
eyes in yawning because you're tired and
like what a useful signal thank you very
much for letting me know I had always
assumed that that was like a like a
thing that we learned from cartoons was
like oh you rub your eyes when you get
tired like I'll Tweety birds fly on your
head when you get hit by a 2x4 no this
is a thing that is ingrained in humans
and I had no idea until I had a baby for
the record I think Tweety birds do kind
of fly around your head when you get hit
by a 2x4 but I read about this I
actually did some research and like some
people oh well I bet your research is
gonna be wrong so I'm gonna be really
good Hank because it comes from Susan
Blackmore psychology professor so there
you go
tired eyes get dry and rubbing
stimulates the lacrimal glands okay I
produce more fluid that's it that's the
reason do you get tired your eyes get
dry and you press them because it makes
a gland release fluid do you think that
there's any doctors of the lacrimal
gland because I bet the lack mirc
lacrimal gland is smaller than the
pituitary gland the LACMA lack lack
the lacrimal gland are paired exocrine
glands one for each eye that are about
the size of an almond so wow that's
bigger than nope I'm wrong I'm wrong I'm
wrong they're shaped like an almond
they're smaller than an almond who's
wondering how I had a whole almond in
there there's a lot of space on your
face don't die bet I bet there's
somebody who just studies the lacrimal
gland like dr. Rosher no you don't know
oh you've got a lacrimal gland problem
he's hidden do the lacrimal gland expert
you just go to an eye doctor or I I
don't know
is this a good bit I might be stupid I
yeah I in general I feel like it's
because there's like itchiness and
irritation and that might because of the
dryness it might because you just like
yeah it would probably become the
because of the dryness and you just like
it's sort of like scratching an itch
when you rub your eyes because when you
get tired your eye get itchy there you
go all right we have to question that
happens to babies and it's so cute it is
really so babies don't know how to shade
they look we know right yeah and that's
part of what makes it so cute
I find whenever little kids do things
that are super cliche but they're
unaware of like the larger narrative
arcs of the social order I find it
completely adorable
and then once they learn that like this
is the thing I'm supposed to do it's
like oh my god stop yeah no totally
that's called adolescence this next
question comes from Alice who writes
Dear John and Hank I'm a probe by the
way I'm only answering questions from
Alice's today Hank I don't know if
you've noticed that it's my new policy
well we've got a dude we've got enough
questions in the in the archive now that
we could probably actually do an episode
where we only answer questions from one
person's name I'll do Alice's and also
Henry's those are the only two names on
here now Dear John and Hank I'm a
primary care provider working in Canada
oh you should talk to the other Alice
she had a question you might know the
answer to and I see so many new babies
for their first visits and subsequent
visits most of these visits include
vaccinations against an assortment of
diseases I've had some difficulty with
some parents who don't want to vac
their children for various reasons I
haven't yet had any success in
convincing any of them that vaccinating
is the way to go even after telling them
all of the data I was wondering if you
have any advice on how to communicate
with these kinds of people people who
are stuck in their own thought processes
and struggle to engage in other thought
processes not in Wonderland Alice here's
the thing Alice I don't neither do i
Alice I did make a video on scishow
called the science of anti vaccination
which is one of my favorite shows we've
ever done that goes into the psychology
of how people get stuck in those thought
processes and how and like the the
biases that lead us to make decisions
that are not ultimately in the best
interests of you know the the people
that we love the most in the world and
also the entire social order and that's
a really like this is a really hard one
and it's worrying and I don't like what
we find over and over again is kind of
engaging people with these ideas sets
them more it like it puts them on the
defensive and they they start to tie it
to their identity and once it's part of
their identity fighting against it is
like is like literally fighting with
them it's a battle that they are being
that they are that they are fighting to
preserve themselves and that's no good
so there was the study done recently
that took a group of people who believed
that tax cuts lead to higher overall
federal revenue this is a common
misconception that because tax cuts spur
growth that growth will lead to more
economic production which will be
taxable and then the tax revenue will go
up even though the tax rates have gone
down it's a compelling idea
unfortunately it's just not true well
well but if we could take the tax rate
all the way down to zero the government
would have infinite money well I mean
that is one of the ways of pointing out
that it's not true another way is by
looking at all of the tax cuts in
American history so we've seen again and
again in US history that when we cut tax
rates it does lead to increased economic
activity people debate how much but it
does which is taxable
but nonetheless overall federal tax
revenue goes down and so that's a really
consistent story in the history of
taxation in the US and in this study
they showed people this documentation
and then at the end of the study people
on average were more convinced than they
had been before that lowering taxes
leads to more overall government revenue
and I do not know what to do about this
problem I don't think by the way it is a
problem unique to people who have that
particular misconception there are
probably a lot of misconceptions that I
have that I also struggle to let go of
in the face of evidence and I don't know
how to solve this problem Alice I think
it is a big problem that's why I wanted
to read your question and I have no
solutions yeah the other thing that I
it's almost as if as soon as it becomes
a point on which you can have an opinion
people will become divided on it and
that is a thing I know that we've been
talking about this I'm on tour and on
vlogbrothers that is part of the thing
that like worries me about the call to
always have an opinion on everything
that that the social internet I think in
particular makes us feel because as soon
as we sort of like establish an opinion
it becomes part of our identity and it
becomes a point of division and it and
like you know a thing that used to be
just like you know vaccines like fewer
babies died these things are good
becomes something that is a sudden
political piece of contention that you
know can that devalues our opinion of
the expertise of doctors but also phrase
the fabric of like not just like the
social order but like the the tools that
we use to prevent us from getting sick
and we do now see a lot more people you
know children getting whooping cough and
measles and all these diseases that we
just shouldn't have to deal with because
we have ways of preventing them slightly
off topic Hank did you know that I had
whooping cough
oh really yeah when I was in college aha
no yeah do you remember that now yeah I
got I did get vaccinated for it but the
vaccine sometimes wears off and there
was a very small outbreak of whooping
cough at my tiny little college I think
it was like six people and I was one of
the six and I can tell you whooping
cough blows like I mean it's terrible
I would coffin till I threw up almost
every day for like a month and a half
and I would be like this is so stupid
and I also I had a hundred degree fever
for like a month and a half I was like
this is the stupidest disease I have
ever had and I've had some stupid
diseases over the years so anyway yeah
I'm opposed to whooping cough that just
wanted to put that out there one of
John's opinions that he's holding on to
I'm holding on to that opinion I am
opposed to a whooping cough I think it
is a dumb disease and I think it should
be eliminated from humans hard stop this
next question comes from NJ who asks
dear Hank and John Hank where do you
find your Mars news how could I find out
more about Mars what websites books or
magazines should I read I love your
podcast but mostly the Mars news wear
sunblock
MJ well thanks for your question NJ
you'll love my new podcast is just all
Mars news I find my Mars news in the
same places that I you find regular news
I do it I got a new phone recently and
it's disturbingly good at knowing what
my interests are so for example just
just because my brother is John Green
it's always showing me the scores of the
AFC Wimbledon games and and there's
always always somewhere on that front
page sometimes there's there's stories
about shirts because I run it I run a
merchandise company so like it knows
that I'm into shirts so recently I
started getting started getting news
articles about shirt companies or like
shirt science or that's it it's gonna be
reporting to you like what what are the
cotton prices for today which would be
great I'd be into that but yeah it also
tell it's also always throw in Mars news
at me so so since I got this phone if
I've sort of had it an easier time
finding the Mars news it just sort of
comes to me when I'm tired of looking at
Twitter and I swipe to the left and
suddenly I'm confronted with you know
bummers some bombers but also usually
some Mars news and but yeah there's a
there's a few great science websites out
there Universe Today is one that I go to
a lot Scientific American has always
been my favorite science publication and
so I will sometimes go to Scientific
American and search for Mars and see if
they've got anything for me but also
just go to Google News and search Mars
and then get rid of all the stories
about Bruno Mars and Mars corporation
and you're left with stories about Mars
Hank you're disturbingly intelligent
phone reminded me of something which is
that there is a pretty widespread
conspiracy theory that maybe isn't a
conspiracy theory about how our phones
are listening to us even when we are not
aware of the fact that they're listening
to us and we think of them as being off
and that maybe it's using stuff that we
say to target our advertising so I just
want to take this opportunity to say to
everyone who's listening to dear Hank
and John I am really struggling with the
question of whether Tide detergent is
worth it is it really different from
generic brands are there other forms of
laundry detergent like all or cheer that
might be better for my family than Tide
detergent I'm just gonna see if anything
happens as a result of that everybody
does play that part of the podcast out
loud so that your phone is hearing John
talk and you report back to us if you
get a lot of detergent Alexa slash
Facebook slash Google slash Twitter
slash some company that you don't even
know exists and that you didn't put on
your phone but it's still there thinks
of that I just I'm just thinking about
whether or not I'm gonna start using a
different detergent I think it's time
for me to consider changing my detergent
to a different laundry detergent there I
think we've got it Hank I'm
it if if it can be done we did it it's
like that time that I accidentally on
purpose ordered many copies of The Fault
in Our Stars by saying on the podcast
hey Alexa I'm not gonna say the rest of
it
because people got so actually and
justifiably mad at me if not you're
using you heard power for bad John
alright Nick this next question comes
from Libby who asks Dear John and Hank
peeing in the shower fine
Thank You Libby I mean it's your shower
well or is it well if it isn't it's not
fine don't pee on anyone elses anything
except toilet water hey this is one of
many questions I don't have to look at
in my own personal life because of baths
thank God for baths which have solved so
many problems for me including the
problem of whether it's okay to pee in
the shower because one thing is for
certain it's not okay to pee in the bath
is a problem then because you can't pee
while you're bathing the wheel it's not
a problem I mean it's you act like my
bathtub and my toilet are in different
zip codes when in fact they are perhaps
four feet from each other so I I I'm not
a shower peer but I do like when I when
I get into the shower I will often be
like oh now I have to pee and I think
that this is kind of why there's so much
shower peeing that happens because like
as soon as you like get all nice and
warm your sphincters relax and it's like
a I you know what I could do right now I
can really go for a whiz and so yeah and
also like it's all going to the same
place like you'd have to worry about
that it's there is something about when
people bring up peeing that makes you
need to pee in fact it's I know because
it's happening to me right now
like I was fine 45 seconds ago and now
I'm like I don't know if I can make it
to the end of the pod without peeing
uh-huh
so I've we've inserted a bit of a
ticking time bomb into the podcast
because this week in Ryan's is gonna be
real rushed it's gonna be very short
this week because and and the this
week's Ryan is
going to be like Niagara Falls is the
Atacama Desert as everything is fine
there's no gas is brought to you by
needing to pee needing to pee an ongoing
issue since 45 seconds ago this podcast
has also brought to you by laundry
detergent this podcast is also brought
to you by whooping cough whooping cough
a great way to cough and vomit in this
bag I finally brought to you by your
lacrimal glands your lacrimal glands
they are the shape not the size of an
almond that's I actually don't know how
big they are I couldn't really figure
that out from the Wikipedia page we also
have an actual sponsor today hey sorry
blocks story blocks so John I make
videos for a living I don't know if you
know that about me and also you yeah and
there's been since the beginning of us
doing that some various ways to get
media to include legally in those videos
and it has always been very high they're
very hard or very expensive and often
that leads us to doing things that are
maybe a little bit like shouldn't be
doing them like taking pictures that
maybe we shouldn't be using and it is so
wonderful to now have a story box
subscription which I learned about from
a different podcast and have been able
to include you know for a price that I
can afford and that isn't a big deal for
for me include great video great audio
great pictures in my videos and you know
I like I've been doing this for years
now using story blocks and it's a
wonderful service that works really well
and much better than the services I was
using before yeah you can get an ongoing
membership two story blocks which is
what Hank and I do but you can they also
have a library of paid clips where you
can like sort of pay per per thing or
per image and it works really well and
as Hank said it solves a huge problem in
the world of online media which is that
we all want to be
making sure that we're using other
people's content appropriately and that
they're being compensated for it
properly and appropriately and that has
been very difficult for the first you
know many years of internet creation and
story box really is a wonderful solution
to this problem you go to a story blocks
comm slash dear Hank and John to learn
more about story blocks and also you can
sign up through there and the thing I
use I pay a hundred and forty nine
dollars per year for a story Abbas and
that gives me access to like like four
hundred thousand images one hundred and
fifty thousand videos a hundred thousand
audio clips those things are in like the
the things there are increasing like the
number of things are always going up and
that's like it's nice to know it is a
yearly price instead of as a monthly
price because I am gonna use it all the
time and I like to just be able to sort
of jump over there and grab stuff when
I'm making a video it's really nice to
be able to talk about a product that I
use personally and and that makes my
content better and makes my life easier
yeah and also we have to say makes crash
course in scishow and oh yeah stuff that
we do better as well by offering this
huge content library it's it's made
things a lot easier for us in all of our
educational content making so we are
grateful two-story blocks for sponsoring
this podcast but also for creating a
service that we really use in like yeah
and the nice thing is the people who are
making those like vectorized images or
taking the photographs or the video the
people who are doing that are getting
paid so those creators are also getting
supported through story blocks it's a
good marketplace that connects creators
together to help make better content
exist in the world
thank you story blocks alright let's get
to another question from our listeners
this one comes from Bailey who writes
Dear John and Hank I've recently met a
guy and we've gone on a few dates
because I am in high school he asked me
to his homecoming dance and I accepted
expecting a night of food and fun I said
yes because I thought they would be food
and if there's not gonna be food I'm
going to really fun that's a great
that's a great reason to say yes to a
homecoming
it's like I've been told that there will
be light snacks and punch and I'm in
when I went to get ready with some of
his friends one of them introduced me to
her parents as his girlfriend this took
me aback because I did not realize that
I was already in relationship with this
guy because we'd never spoken about it
now I've heard that he has told people
we are dating and I don't know how I
feel about the guy so what should I do
I am very busy with school and work and
the college gosh
I'm unsure if I'm able to have a
relationship right now any dubious
advices appreciated high school drama
and horseradish Bailey I mean Bailey
sauce it's gonna like first of all their
words have various meetings but I'm
gonna take you back to the first
sentence of your email where you said I
recently met a guy and we've gone on a
few dates you are yeah dating him
well you've gone on a few dates with him
that's not exactly the same thing as
being being someone oh but I will say
that you are dating like that's what's
happening but if Bailey doesn't feel
comfortable being called this guy's
girlfriend that's probably right no
issue because in all likelihood that
means that this person did not say hey
are you my girlfriend or do you want to
be my girlfriend or should we like
identify this relationship as a
girlfriend boyfriend thing and then yeah
instead just started telling his pals
this is my girlfriend
I I kind of I see Bailey's point like I
feel like this Bailey this is probably a
moment to take a step back and say just
from your email you may not be that
psyched about this relationship it seems
like you're mostly in it for the food
and fun which is great by the way I
think that is a pretty good reason when
you're in high school too and also in
adulthood to go on dates frankly when
Sarah and I go on dates it's mostly for
the food and fun Bailey I will say that
like I I don't know when you like are
supposed to have the talk and figure out
what the relationship is like is that a
thing that happens because for me it was
always like hey by the way I am so into
you and I want this to be forever and
then girl
for me really no for me I always would
have that talk or I felt like that talk
was it should be like an ongoing thing
and I don't know
I listen Hank I'm not an expert in any
of this but certainly like I do remember
when Sarah and I admittedly we were not
in high school we did not go to the
homecoming dance together or anything
but I do remember when I said to Sarah
like hey are we gonna be like like a
like an item like we're gonna be
whatever however you want to phrase it
are we gonna be boyfriend-girlfriend are
we gonna be in an exclusive relationship
whatever whatever they're like
constructs that you want to use around
it you need to like have that
conversation with the other person
before you have it with your buds agreed
agreed
and I actually like I do remember being
sort of new to this whole game and
thinking I was someone's boyfriend what
I was in fact just died seeing them and
and bringing it up and then being like
oh oh no oh no no no no no no Hank no
and I was like oh okay well it's I mean
yeah it's inherently uncomfortable and
like these are these are difficult
conversations to have but I also think
that's like part of what makes them so
important agreed this next question
comes from Kyla who asks dear Hank and
John late at night when I'm trying to
sleep
all I can seem to do is come up with
unrealistic fantasies that keep me up
I'll be laying in bed trying to sleep
when all of a sudden I think about
myself in a world that literally cannot
exist how does one turn off their
imagination for long enough to sleep for
eight hours
extremely sleep-deprived Kyla wait
what's the world I don't know I feel
widely it exists why wouldn't that have
been brought up by Kyla in this very
short question that obviously had space
to give us some information about these
these fantasy worlds that I'm not very
curious about Kyla I'm not gonna be able
to sleep tonight worrying about what
these fantasy worlds might or might not
be
that's on you I mean your name is you
just need less sleep in the world Kyla I
don't want to criticize our listeners it
sounds like come on
you could be an icy tail's protagonist
in any number of these fantasy stories
you just maybe write them down I said
John I do have sleep tips I'm like I've
become informed on sleep tips because
one I make science videos for a living
and two people are always asking me how
I sleep
one tip is that I have a medication that
makes me sleepy so that's don't
necessarily do that get all sort of
colitis and take that one too it's like
it's really all about like like
structuring your day so that sleep
happens it starts at the same time it
ends at the same time and it happens in
a place that is too devoted to sleep and
so you are not spending time in your bed
doing things that aren't sleep so that
your mind knows that like this is the
sleep place not the place for fantasy
imaginings and if you are having those
fantasy imaginings and it's not good and
it's not gonna happen
like leave the sleep place and go
somewhere else until you feel sleepy
kyla I would talk to a doctor not Hank
about this this is literally advice that
I was given by a doctor well sure sure
but not like Kyle is doctor each
individual is different I think that's
good advice I just think like if it's
become an issue in your life like don't
don't turn to advice podcasts and I do
think that if it's something you're
really concerned about it's probably
time to talk to your doctor about it
because while Hanks tips are great
nothing stands in for actual medical
advice quite like actual medical
professionals John do you ever feel like
that that those times in your life when
you couldn't get to sleep we're actually
like really useful and wonderful like
like like when you got excited about an
idea or where we're creating you know a
world or a character or something like
that you just laying in bed and you just
can't stop stop working on a problem
very occasionally what would almost
always happen or what does almost always
happen in my experience is that I
finally am like okay I've got to get up
and write this down because this stuff
is great this is this is fascinating
I've finally found my way through to a
solution
and then I write it down and I'm like
what is this this makes no sense it's
almost like this was developed by a
tired person
it wasn't thinking at all rationally
yeah it's almost it's almost as if it's
almost as if this person was having a
dream about solving a problem not
actually solving a problem on a few
occasions because I always hear about
writers who like come up with great
solutions to problems in their books and
dreams or else some come up with great
premises for new books and dreams and so
on a few occasions I have woken up and
thought like it happened it finally
happened for me and I write down the
dream and I'm like okay here's how I'm
gonna solve the problem in Turtles all
the way down there's a baseball game and
they're in the dugout it's the visitors
dugout and it's the seventh-inning and I
keep writing and I'm like holy crap like
how did I think how did I ever think
that this was going to solve a problem
when it's it's obvious that like this is
all happening inside of a magical world
where none of the rules of narrative or
physics apply yeah yeah yeah I mean I
have I have I would say that I have had
experiences a handful of times where
like I had too much coffee at 6 o'clock
at night and it was 2:00 in the morning
and I still couldn't get to sleep and
and I came up with something pretty
pretty amazing but in general I think
that it's just as likely to happen
anytime that I'm not occupying myself
with something like I tend to always do
these days where I've always dupe like
I'm on the phone or I'm listening to a
podcast or I'm reading a book or I'm
like driving the car and listening to
music and or something in those moments
when I'm like actually not occupied that
there is a like a surprising number of
times and it's just like oh well now I'm
thinking about this problem and that's
helpful to just you know have time to
just think ah I feel like I never have
time to just think anymore
and Hank let me encourage you to explore
the possibility of clearing honeysuckle
out of your backyard I've been about 60
hours doing it so far I'm going to
we're back next week but so far what I
found is that when my brain has quiet
time mostly it wants to be quiet I'm
expecting that at some point my brain
will be like I'd like to start having
some thoughts again now but right now my
brains just like Shanee suckle get it
out of the ground make sure that did you
get that did you get the stump make sure
to get the stump that's good John yeah I
don't think that I don't think that's
the experience I would have hmm but I
also don't have a bunch of honeysuckle
on my yard
something like somebody who hasn't tried
it yet the other thing I've been doing
is creating this brick path this I
blazed a trail through my backyard and
then now I'm slowly breaking the path
one brick at a time I got bricks from
this this abandoned building a long long
long ago ruin from the early 20th
century on our property and just the act
of doing that Hank oh my god it's so
much better it's so much better than
going to VidCon medic's I don't want to
gloat but I feel like I've found like a
glitch in the matrix and at least for
one week this is the perfect solution I
don't think I could do it forever but I
intend to find out all right this next
question is from Natalie who asks dear
Hank and John
I was recently listening to an NPR
interview where the guest explained that
his high school experience and had where
the guest explained to his high school
experience and his life as an
Episcopalian I was thinking John Green
and this guy would probably be really
great friends and then the host said it
was John Green why do you know so much
different it's crazy
anyway how the heck does NPR work are
there local stations for cut for
counties and there's some headquarters
Congrats on the new book Congrats on the
new book guys yeah well so I was on
fresh air that might have been the
interview that you heard with Terry
Gross which was the most nervous I've
ever been Hank knows the
because he was with me right before he
was freaking out first off Natalie I
don't know why I sound it sounded
different in that interview that that
you heard but I listened to it as well
and I also thought that I sounded
different I was listening to my voice
and I was like that's weird
I don't I and I don't know why maybe it
was because I was so incredibly nervous
about the prospect of speaking to Terry
Gross who's one of my like longtime
heroes but it was it was cool it was a
very cool experience being on fresh air
by far the best part was the very
beginning when Terry Gross came on the
line and she said um are there two lines
in your book that you got from our radio
show and I was like yeah and she was
like that's cool and I was like yeah
thanks thanks for reading it and she was
like yeah I liked it and that was the
best part yeah the interview part was
good but like her noticing the - the -
fresh air moments in Turtles all the way
down was pretty amazing I thought you
were gonna say that the best moment for
you was when Terry Gross called us the
v-log brothers oh I didn't actually hear
her say that she recorded that intro
later and it was pretty epic to be
called the v-log brothers
oh man it's not her fault you know it's
not her fault naming the YouTube channel
a bad name it's true that's on us Hank
ultimately that's on us as for how NPR
works that's not really my area of
expertise in this particular case I
think I was in Nashville and I went to
the Nashville NPR station and they had a
little studio set aside for me for that
hour and a half and I listened to Terry
Gross talk to me on my headphones the
same way I'm listening to Hank talk to
me now only it was kind of a much
fancier version of the setup that we
currently have I also don't know how NPR
works I'm much more familiar with PBS
because we actually work with them but
NPR is as far as I can tell
funded by mostly its listeners according
to every pledge drive that's right
so donate to your local NPR station if
you enjoy fresh air as much as I do okay
let's answer one more question before we
get to the all-important news from Mars
and AFC Wimbledon this question comes
from Magdalene who writes Dear John and
Hank as someone who frequents the coffee
shop across the street from my school
I've been presented with an issue that
only grows over time having been
diagnosed with things
means that I have trouble doing some
ordinary tasks one of them being paying
the cashier I check and recheck that I
have the right amount in just a few
bills so as not to hold up the line but
this leaves me with multiple coins and
change which over time have built up to
an insurmountable amount should I
continue paying with just bills what if
I hold up the people behind me by using
the change please help I don't know how
I could possibly do a name specific
sign-off Magdalen I mean obviously you
have a name specific sign-off it's Mary
comma Magdalene okay good I'll allow it
this this is not I don't understand how
the paying with coins holds up the line
especially if you have time to get the
mic sorted and ready to go because so
you know in advance Magdalene how much
your coffee order is gonna cost right
like you've probably order the same
order yeah taxes don't changed right so
you know it's gonna be two dollars and
fifty eight cents so what I would do I'm
totally sympathetic to your concern
about holding up the line it's something
that I worry about to know what I would
do is just get those eight quarters five
dimes one nickel and three inexplicable
pennies out have them in your hand try
to organize them as much as you can by
shape and size actually you know what
don't use the pennies Magdalene just
just get to sixty just get just eight
quarters and six dimes and hand it over
and say that's two dollars and sixty
cents I do not need change thank you
well and then you leave your tip at the
tip jar additionally and if they give
you the two cents you can put that there
- which is what I do every penny I ever
receive that's actually a better
solution Hank over time Magdalene the
way to get rid of your change is a
dollar at a time put it in the tip jar
yeah that is also a great way to do it
there's also places that will take your
change and turn it into dollars for you
they're called banks don't you don't use
the coin star machine that's it that's
that's a racket there take a big
percentage and the bank will do it you
just have to my favorite thing I do so
John I have I have a secret I have a
secret embarrassing secret and people
didn't get to hear my other embarrassing
secret in there never will so I want to
tell you this embarrassing secret
because it's pretty embarrassing and I
don't think anybody knows about it
okay so Coinstar machines they have this
little tray that you dump all your
change into and it's got a slot then
there's little holes in it and in
America the hole is just smaller than a
dime
so what dime can't fall through it but
other stuff can so like that stuff
doesn't end up in the machine and one of
my secret joys in life is to put my head
into a Coinstar machine and see what has
fallen through the dime holes and just
yeah I mean I head in there and I'm like
whoo and that is not even within 12
orders of magnitude of the most
embarrassing thing about you I agree but
it's something right just Hank green
sticking his head into the Coinstar
machine because you got to get your head
in there
you can't like see it from outside you
have to like get put and it's like the
whole grocery stores around and I like I
can't help myself I'm gonna put my head
in the going star machine now I think
it's fine the I actually have a bigger
concern the then the Coinstar head issue
which is that I think that you just
referred to yourself in the third person
and that can never happen again with I
was being the pupil around talking about
me right but that's also rather
presumptuous
I just wouldn't be like oh look it's
Hank green with his head in the
cloistered machine they would be like oh
look at that
random middle-aged dude with his head in
the Coinstar machine well I'm gonna take
my head out and then there's like one of
the people is the crash course van and
they're like wow okay I thought that was
just a random middle-aged dude with his
head in the corn starfish team but it's
that guy who taught me and not to be in
physiology instead they're like oh my
gosh it's dad that's John Green's
brother oh I mean I I only I only made
that comment Hank to try to give you
some real well-defined consequences for
referring to yourself in the third
person are we helping Magdalene out with
her problem at all I Oh John I
so yeah also have a new phone that I'd
mentioned earlier today I might like it
a lot and it
I heard numbers into it and then I just
hold the phone up to a thing and put my
finger on the on the fingerprint reader
and it just pays not everywhere but if
Magdalen if your place has one of these
it is so much faster than paying with
cash it's faster than a credit card it's
faster than the chip thing it's faster
than everything it's immediate and also
not a lot of people use it yet so
everybody's sort of like what did you
just do and then you can like it's me
Hank green I pay with my finger and buy
the coins machine humming god I can
smell it coming it's not a good bit I
don't like it as a joke what's the
week's nice Mars so John the thing that
keeps popping up in my Mars news at the
top of my phone for like three days now
it's very frustrating to me but I'm
gonna tell you this this story I'm gonna
read you the headline in the hopes that
your phone will hear you read it and
then be like okay he knows that one time
to move on yeah Russian prodigy who
claims he lived on Mars before being
reborn on earth baffles scientists in
parentheses video that headline might be
peak 2017 so yeah I like I don't know
how to tell my phone that I don't want
fake Mars news like experts are
reportedly baffled by the testimony of
maryska a young Russian prodigy from the
city of Volgograd who claims that he
lived on a war ravaged planet Mars long
ago before being reborn on earth so
apparently scientists are baffled there
why is that why is that baffling I
because because he has detailed
knowledge of space and the conditions on
other planets there's no way of that you
know no way to acquire that on the
internet nope and I guess all the things
he knows there's no way he could he
could
about the places except that if he was
making up I guess would be my favorite
part about his his idea is that when he
was a Martian he was seven feet tall and
and he was 35 years old because Martians
had mastered the prevention of aging and
all Martians stopped aging and became
semi immortal at 35 years of age which I
guess it's like a fairly good time to
become semi immortal but like if I could
probably pick like 27 no like I feel
like at 35 my like my peak physical
fitness was already behind me all
actually in my case it was ahead of me
but only because I'd set such a low bar
earlier in life yeah well I think I'm
very excited about that news from Mars
and congratulations on the discovery of
life on Mars at last in the form of semi
immortal 35 year olds it's over iske
says human life will change when the
Sphinx is opened it has an opening
mechanism somewhere behind the ear I do
not remember exactly but he has an
incredibly specific memory well I think
the news from ASU Wimbledon is that in
really an encouraging sign AFC one that
have just signed a 20-year old prodigy
from Russia named Burris Kia is e20 or
is he infinity I mean we could really
stand to have a striker who does an age
that would be a real gift 35 is probably
a little too old if we could set it I
think we'd set it a little younger AFC
Wimbledon Hank were in the first round
of the FA Cup you might remember the FA
Cup Inc because a few years ago AFC will
then made it to the third round of the
FA Cup where they played a Liverpool
Football Club in one of the most
exciting and weird days of my life and
this year in the first round the eve of
the FA Cup they played Lincoln City
which is the team I think from the
seventh tier and they they won the game
one to nothing hey all right
who's
Gold John the Messi for Montserrat I'll
Taylor does that mean it does that mean
that his leg is feeling better that
means that he is recovered from his
injury and is now back to scoring goals
for AFC Wimbledon which is great because
he is the only person scoring goals for
AFC Wimbledon at the moment AFC
Wimbledon are now headed to the second
round of the FA Cup where they're going
to take on a significantly more
challenging opponent in the form of
Charlton Athletic if they were to win
that game which given the current run of
form I would say is not super likely but
if they were to win that game they would
move on to the third round of the FA Cup
which is when you can get teams like
Manchester United and Liverpool and
Chelsea and potentially a huge payday so
it would be great to win that second
round game but the arc of history is
long and right now a little troubling
right right sorry to hear about the
trouble spot I've got so it was that
team from your league did you tell me
that Matt didn't listen correct yes I
told you that and you didn't listen
yeah I believe that Lincoln's current
city is currently in the seventh tier oh
wow so you one by one one goal over a
seventh tier team well let me go ahead
and confirm that for you Hank because it
might for all I know
no they're in league two they're in the
fourth tier of English football it's
barely even an upset yeah alright that
makes me feel much better we beat a
fourth tier English soccer team the kind
of soccer team we might be next year if
we don't watch out all right I'm sorry
about that situation that I have swimmin
in it does make me legitimately nervous
ya know me too it's the first thing I
think about every single morning I think
what can I do to ensure that AFC will
did remain a third tier English soccer
team and then I turn over to Sarah and I
opened my mouth as if to speak and she
says absolutely not well I agree with
her deeply
thank you for potting with me John thank
you for potting we're gonna go make our
patreon only podcast this week in Ryan's
right now over at patreon.com slash dear
Hank and John if you want to listen to
the worst ten minutes of audio available
on the internet each week subscribe over
there to this week in Ryan's but thank
you for potting with me Hank and thanks
to everybody for listening this podcast
is produced by rosianna halse rojas and
Sheridan Gibson it's edited by nicholas
jenkins Victoria bon giorno is our head
of community and communications the
theme music that you're hearing right
now and at the begin of the podcast is
from the great gunnarolla and as they
say in our hometown don't forget to be
awesome
[Music]